they've all had to move everything
themselves over the new network so it's
been a lot of moving ah no it's it's
great we're so grateful to CBS for
launching the show for putting Melissa
on buildings all over the world and for
all their support but we were all
thrilled to learn about this because
it's there's just there's something
really nice we obviously do a lot Greg
Berlanti Andrew Kreisberg myself we all
do so much with the CW so there's just a
real shorthand they do you say metahuman
they know what you're talking about so
we're really glad we're just happy to
have everyone in the same place
literally and and channel life nice and
now you're a members of the flower
Rovers yeah well are we have there is
there any discussion yet as to how oh
yes yeah oh yes okay it's very
complicated and I'd have to kill you but
no worry it's we're super excited for
the crossovers over all four shows it's
gonna be an incredible
all right so how did you swing getting
Superman for this exit next to them I
mean it's not um it wasn't hard and to
be honest it just that in season one
this shows about Cara and it's about
Supergirl and so that was a sort of
confused matters a little bit to have
Superman there but now I think everyone
you guys know her now right a sense of
who she is and this show is about family
and it's about the family that you make
as an adult and this family that's come
together and then it's also about the
family you came from and Clark is now
now that Laura Benanti is full time
playing Melania Trump we have Clark to
represent the family so I think it's
only natural now that Cara reconnects
with him all right and I know this is a
huge deal this is massive but this is
Supergirl and it is about Melissa
Benoist
this has been such a great season for
you what great for people who didn't
know you from Glee or anything like that
what a great ride how has it been I'm
just happy to have made it out alive
um guys I like the last season I don't I
honestly look back and I don't know how
I I did a lot of the things that we did
and I challenged I was challenged in so
many ways and did things I had no idea I
was capable of doing and I feel like
I've grown so much kind of
simultaneously along with Cara and we
fell in love with the whole ensemble
this year you guys gave us every reason
to love them including David who we all
thought he was a baddie when he Truman
at what point at what point did you guys
all feel like a team there you they want
around yeah yeah yeah and a pilot yeah
yeah sure and did that make these the
long hours and the you know the all the
work and the physical stuff did that
make it easier knowing you guys we're
all working together on this Adam
yes we're a team who is the first to be
like I don't want to get in the harness
that was me definitely was no pot that
was me oh I feel I being in the harness
is different for a guy yes yes yeah but
you have to decide very early it doesn't
feel good I weigh 235 so that the
harness is a little different i chafe
like that it's more um are you so David
you are you in the damn Martian
Manhunter whoa Martian Manhunter on
television um and lastly or like I said
we all thought this guy was going to be
a villain how was the you know kind of
sitting on that secret and knowing that
this guy was going to eventually go
green well actually when I did the panel
this time last year I had no idea I was
gonna be Martian Manhunter so it was a
it was a great reveal for me and it was
just so so funny to look online
the next day when he was revealed to see
all these videos of people just jumping
up and down and screaming when he
actually revealed himself as the Martian
Manhunter was just awesome with that
scene of your your performance in that
scene I am I was so lucky to be in the
room with him and during that scene we
make a great please impact what we did
you guys really do you do you got I love
this team and also Kyler I gotta say I
think you had chemistry with everyone
living like every episode of that [ __ ]
I crush it like she hates Jenelle I
don't think she liked James that much
though oh my god you met you out a
little bit cuz you know you're digging
on the sisters
hmm yeah yeah man so where is Alex
headed this year because last year also
at this time we didn't know that Alex
was gonna be such a badass
wow thanks you know what's really cool
about this season is we've established
so much about who alex is in the de Oh
her relationship with Jean and that
journey and where that went from and
then where it is now and then her
relationship obviously was with Cara and
kind of established Alex that way but
didn't really get to see very much about
her outside of those elements and so
this season is an opportunity for us to
kind of learn a little bit more about
her and just kind of see who she is what
she wants
cuz now she's kind of in a place where
she can sort of make those decisions a
little bit and she's always always has
taken care of car and since she's come
into her own so much it's kind of like
okay I have a little room to kind of
maybe not be in the cave all the time
maybe not even loft all the time where
does Alex live I have no idea I didn't
ever she's live in the hallway cuz
that's where we always see her just
coming into the apartment she's like a
dreamer yeah I just skid in jeopardy
nobody it is when the journey between
you know John and Cara and and Alex to
figure out where Jeremiah Danvers is if
he's out there and what happened and
that's kind of like their unified
journey in a sense thanks alright and
Maccabi you are ready for romance next
season define ready and define romance
well last time we saw you and Cara
things were not platonic yeah we ended
up in a lip-lock and yeah yeah long
overdue
yeah and it's weird because I read the
first I read 201 and it starts with our
wedding so that's I thought it was
yes that is really fast I think that's
been rewritten OS oh my dad no it's like
it so it's a workplace relationship it's
it's it's a new relationship so it's
gonna have up and downs and some
tumultuous things and you know she's
still finding out who she is as a woman
and I'm still finding out who I am you
know and I think that may get in the way
a little bit too so we'll see what do
you guys think yeah I don't even ask you
yeah specifically though because I'm
guessing he'll probably have to get
clearance from Superman we have we have
we have some bro time to talk oh yeah we
got a little bit yeah there's some bro
time coming over - no nice no Jimmy a
little bit Jeremy so I my dream for when
is that every season he falls in love
with a villain I want me good I wanted
to have like the worst tinder experience
this wouldn't really like vendor then
cuz it's like villain for this vendor
vendor
I like it vendor dude I told it I call
him - okay is there do you feel like
this guy is perpetually going to be the
one who's like what why thank you in the
in the romance to be talking about win
right yes yes when I had those
experiences earlier on um no actually no
I don't think that I mean I think that
would be really funny and maybe we'll
play with that for a while but um you
know in in the first season we saw when
kind of go from this like meek
unassuming completely unconfident guy to
you know meeting is finding out about
cars powers and through you know helping
her and meeting all these other people
and meeting James and he sort of has
come into his own and grown more
confident and I don't know I think
confidence is pretty sexy so maybe he'll
find some somebody a little ball alright
oh that bet that maybe won't break his
heart but I don't know I don't know but
I also think you know it's it's we
thought we saw a lot of wins romantic
escapades last season and and this
season I think we're gonna get to see
you know when kind of reaching his full
potential because he was he was an IT
guy at Catco when really he's this great
computer genius so we'll see him kind of
using his skills in a more productive
manner okay well that's what I wanted to
follow up with those um it is in
addition to his bad taste in women he
also has great taste in tech and when he
ever he's in the de oh he's like a kid
in a candy store
do you think there's a possibility that
he would end up moonlighting there maybe
me you know it could be I mean he's
already I feel like he already has been
moonlighting so I think he's looking for
a straight-up job all right I think it
would make the deal a little bit more
fun I think so yeah a little serious
right now you think Johnny could handle
an idea I mean that's a good idea yeah
we need some more laughter in the de oh
yeah that's a good idea it's pretty
heavy
all right so mr. hoechlin yes mr. Tyler
hoechlin
this is not a minor character this is an
icon and you have gone now from wolf of
teen to a Man of Steel what is this like
finding out Oh they've picked me to play
Superman um definitely incredibly
surreal it's a it's very I don't know I
I know the the character represents so
much to so many people I was um I was
with a friend who was with his mom and
his mom's boyfriend and he came up to me
and was had these like I had to shake
your hand out to shake Superman's hand
and that was kind of that weird moment
of oh it's it this is not like a
generational thing this is literally
something spread across so much time
there's a responsibility to that
character so that's something that I
take on with great pride and you know
I'm just excited to kind of see what we
can do with that character in this great
world these guys have created in this
first season so I'm really excited have
you uh have you have you tried on the
suit yet I have not tried on the suit
yet yes that will be that will be a
moment for sure but he looks great in
the Halloween costume right
other places it was a onesie uses
pajamas I tried it on it didn't fit and
then I tried it on I ripped it in half
okay I have it I have a theory that when
literally just has backups of every
superhero costume that he just puts on
and sits around the house there's
certain things that Cara has gotten
involved in as have Alex that Clark
might not be down with such as the
killing of Astra things like that how is
he going to like what brings him I mean
I don't think car was totally down with
the killing of Asheville in fairness uh
yeah I think that they did Clark has a
very different experience of what it
means to have superpowers on earth and
he was raised with them and with certain
values so there's definitely some real
kind of head buddy and philosophical
approaches that are different and we'll
get into all that and the other thing I
just wanted to say those you know
Melissa Benoist is also a superhero and
she's so hard-working and so sweet and
so nice and it's so nice every time any
little girl or boy comes to meet her and
we're all just so lucky that we have an
actual Supergirl playing Supergirl here
all right so let's talk about some stuff
that's coming up in season two because
there's a lot of chatter there's a lot
of rumors assumptions hopes you've got
Maggie Sawyer coming on yeah God for
iana life so what what is the story
there because we know that he is
connected to that woman there's all that
stuff going on what can you tell us I
will say did she's an incredible actress
and really tough and a real badass and I
think one of the things that we're
really proud of is having a lot of
strong badass ladies on television and
she's going to be another one all right
okay um my second man is she uh is she
going to have people in her life that we
could possibly look forward to well
everybody is somebody in their life come
on does that person have a mask
ah no okay um maybe we can get them on
and then you uh you have in Gomez yes
who's so fantastic he's gonna play
snapper Carr and he is he came in and he
really does this sort of like well this
reference will not mean anything but
he's like very Lou Grant hmm for any the
five people here that know what I'm
talking about
eventually they'll remake yeah what's
great is that I think you guys watch the
show a lot of people really respond
public even cat responds really
positively to Supergirl even if Carla
drives her crazy like everybody likes
Supergirl or Cara usually but not not
Ian he really could not he doesn't fall
for either of their tricks which is
really gonna be a lot of fun and then
this is this is so great Lynda Carter as
the president of Lynda Carter is the
president like first of all I want to
know why is the president getting
involved because big things are
happening you I mean big things have to
have a good Superman and Supergirl
together okay so what what should we
expect from this president Wonder Woman
well I think we should expect that a
female president is gonna lead well
we're with her yes are with her hashtag
yes all right and then the big one which
is like the mystery box that they're
selling out on the floor these you can
bite like $20 you get a box and it's
filled with like a bunch of stuff so we
have Chris Wood's coming on as mystery
or surprise DC character yeah can you
tell us about this I mean do you guys
want to know or do you just do want to
just wait until the show airs
maybe I don't think they care very much
I mean maybe if they knew that he was in
the pod Oh
mm-hmm well what would that imply then I
don't know with so many things but yes
that's there's there's the big answer
reveal he's that he's the the hottie in
the potty really funny funny guys to be
hash tagging that once you come on all
right so now that you guys have all
worked together for a year except for
Tyler I want you to look to the person
to your right
and tell me tell us one thing about that
person you've learned mm does it mean I
get you Damian
yes are you I've learned that Damian
hland
does the best moderating a panelist okay
that's going on my reel so Sara go ahead
what if I learned from from David well I
think that we all knew David was a great
actor from his work on homeland and
various other things but I I don't think
we realized how truly phenomenally
talented he is I love that and
and also that apparently everybody even
the Brits like it when he does an
American accent as he does in the night
manager if you haven't seen it I learnt
that Kylie really is a total badass she
is in fights in just all her application
I just think she's probably one of the
best actresses that I've ever worked
with he's only saying that because I
actually punched him in the head once it
hurt for three days Wow
I don't think I don't think we have
enough time for me to really talk about
the lady to my right I have learned the
definition of grace by this one I mean
for someone in her position to handle
this whole famine this whole thing so
gracefully and so tastefully and she's
so kind but not only that I mean even
just sitting at the table reads when
she's reading the script the first time
I'm reading it out loud and I'm just
watching him like she's so good like I
just and then I'm like I think I'm doing
an awful job but so good no she's just
you you are you are a lovely human being
and I just am so grateful that my little
girls get to look up to somebody like
you and she's just inherently
good
what to say about my god I can't wait
I'm nervous you know what I find I have
learned that you are always full of like
the natural remedies he's always got
some like tincture or potion or like Oh
what did you bring to set that one day
uh Paulo Santos that yes which smells
really good but you also brought deer
antler yeah something that was made from
deer antlers and they always are like
obviously like natural and you you
helped me out of a lot of binds so I
don't know that he's the medicine man um
medicine man talking um what I've
learned about Jeremy JJ Jordan the
things I could say about this man
what I will say a couple things I was
like uh he honestly is one of the best
actors I've ever encountered in my life
really he's one of the funniest people
I've ever encountered in my life and
also one of my favorite and it's a joy
to come to work every day see his
smiling smug look I don't know how you
can be how you can smile be smug at the
same time but he's pulled it up I love
work I love working with all these guys
it's it's very jason Priestley it is but
it's amazing and I love this guy I love
I love the entire cast but Jeremy I have
a lot of work together and it's just a
joy
thanks yes wait you're right I guess I
have to say something by you Tyler who I
met sorry
four days okay yeah you just take a shot
take a guess it's fine it doesn't have
to be true just just make him laugh
that's fine what if I just think so I
just stare adoringly at you fer know I
mean I've known this guy for for less
than a week and I could already tell
he's probably one of the nicest most
genuine guys I've ever met uh he's got
he's got just the loveliest eyes
he just he just does that one unbuttoned
just enough just just a tease and and
and I know he has he hasn't tried on the
costume yet come on what you're talking
about
but this just became to wait there are
we can we see you know what Kent can you
do the curl look the hair cream yeah do
it do it do it do it yeah
I just wish I would just wish that
shooting the show is gonna be fun
because it's the worst time you guys bro
trust me okay we're gonna go to audience
questions so you guys want to start
lining up I have a couple of quick ones
um Melissa I always ask you what what
Glee songs do you have on your iPad or
iPod but now I want to know Jeremy which
smash songs do you have on yours
uh I can't let go by Jennifer Hudson man
that was my jam all right okay and David
Ramsey said yesterday on a panel that he
cannot wait to cross over have you guys
considered how you can get John Diggle
from Star City to National City yes yeah
yeah they have
you